[Applause]
and finally new rule americans must
answer the question posed on twitter
last week by representative marger
marjorie taylor-green
should america have a national divorce
now i don't think marjorie taylor-green
should really be a representative at all
she's the house you tell your kids to
avoid on halloween
but her question does represent the
thinking of a lot of americans on both
sides ben shapiro floated the idea that
our best hope now is a friendly
separation of states
66 percent of republicans in the south
say they would support secession to join
a new confederacy
41 of biden voters
want to secede i mentioned this
in this space in our last editorial in
our last show about how trump is right
now behind the scenes spending every
waking moment making the changes needed
to really steal the election next time
because it's either that or trying to
win voters with ideas
[Applause]
crazy but
a lot of people hit me up after that
editorial and i s and said you know what
you scared the [ __ ] out of me good
because now the question they're asking
is what can we do about this slow-moving
coup great question and here's the
answer many will not like
if we want to halt this dissent into
civil war
we have to stop hating each other
and the reason i say that many won't
like that answer is because the act of
hating people you don't exactly agree
with has become
so ingrained so routine for so many
people i think if they stopped they'd
miss it
it's become so normalized now we don't
even notice how often someone online is
wishing someone dead
anyone we disagree with about anything
is evil incarnate and every argument
goes from zero to homicide it doesn't
even have to be about anything important
or consequential you insulted gossip
girl prepare to die
there's a moment in my stand-up act
these days where i asked the audience
rhetorically
what should happen to all of the people
who enabled trump when he was in office
and about half the time someone shouts
out kill them
or hang them
you know besides the fact that wishing
people dead is a terrible place for your
mind to be
if you're wishing them dead you can be
sure they're wishing you did
you want a real war liberals really you
think you're going to win the i want you
dead war you're not you're gonna lose
they have way more guns and they know
how to use them
and with all due respect no one can do
hate like a right-wing conservative
this past saturday i was in the great
city of pittsburgh pa and the man who
drove me in from the airport was from
bosnia
he was there in sarajevo in 1984 when
they had the olympics and he left some
time after that city became a war-torn
hellscape and he said to me
what i am seeing happening here now is
exactly what i saw in bosnia
next door neighbors who despise each
other
he was telling me that hate on this
level can only be sustained for so long
before becoming actual war
last year a war a warehouse blew up in
beirut lebanon everyone agreed it was an
accident
but last week there was a march calling
for the removal of the judge
investigating the incident
and it turned into a street fight with
automatic rifles and rocket-propelled
grenades
over that most emotional of all issues
warehouse safety
because when people despise each other
it doesn't matter what the issues are
when someone hates you they don't hear
what you're saying let alone want to
work with you on an issue
today's republicans don't have issues oh
they have issues
just not like the ones they used to have
balanced budget
they care about that about as much as
they care about the new season of
rupaul's drag race
owning the libs is the only issue
obamacare wasn't a horrible or radical
policy it was desperately needed by many
of the people who fought it
but it came from
but it came from the people they hated
democrats keep thinking they can win
over voters who hate them with better
policies you're dreaming
democrats are always asking why do
republicans vote against their economic
interests because they hate you
[Music]
comedians know this syndrome very well
you can have an act that kills in a good
way
but if you insult the audience if you
make them hate you dead silence
they will not give you that laughter and
if they don't laugh it's not comedy it's
alternative comedy
so
how do we stop trump and the coup
take it down a notch
can we start with that
is that really so hard i know i know it
would be easier if everyone bad would
just die
but that's not a plan and they're not
going to it's up to all of us right left
and center to fix this by de-escalating
so here's everybody's first assignment
captain kirk
was blasted into space last week
and yes you could use that to make a
point about how we need to tax the super
rich more or how we still have problems
on earth or toxic masculinity
yeah you could but how about this don't
just enjoy it
just enjoy it that william shatner
national treasure
spirit animal to virgins
[Music]
and i assume reverse mortgage salesman
went for a rocket ride and came back not
everything has to be political you want
to heal america shut the [ __ ] up for a
while
facebook went down for six hours a
couple of weeks ago
we need to make that happen more
you